what is going on everyone while I have
some channel updates for you some new
things happening on my channel no longer
will there be anything lewd obscene or
possibly inappropriate at all times my
videos will be the same uniformity will
be held above all else because the best
part of YouTube is a complete lack of
variety fuck that let's do some new shit
how's it going guys I'm of course
kidding I haven't talked to you for a
while actually it's been like two days I
make a lot of videos I promised you guys
on Facebook and Twitter that it have
some channel updates for you I have
something new I'd like to try in my
channel and it's not actually new it's
an older segment that I started and
haven't done for a while but I would
like to sort of mold it into something
else something more fun if you guys have
noticed I've been trying to do more
hilarious 'ti reviews that was my new
year's resolution doing at least two a
month I kept that private to myself and
I've been actually doing one every
Sunday surprisingly I've been able to do
that and I'm having a ton of fun doing
it but I'd like to switch it up a little
bit because I've run into a creative
snag something I've wanted to do but
haven't had an outlet to do it in but
now I can you guys remember a video I
did called Toonami retro rewind that was
my kind of mini documentary on Toonami
and how much I loved it I would like to
take the retro rewind segment and sorta
mess with it a little bit but really not
that much and incorporate it into my
regular schedule of videos so nothing's
gonna change at all literally nothing
will change all my new release reviews
are gonna be the same I'll still see as
many new movies as I can but instead of
doing a Hillary ASSA tea every Sunday
I'm gonna do - hilarious --'tis a month
and two retro rewinds a month always on
Sunday know what I'm gonna do with this
segment is not make a 20 minute mini
documentary every other Sunday I just
don't have the time to do that but I
will take something from my past and
discuss it I just want to segment twice
a month where I can talk to you guys
about whatever the only rule of this
segment is that it has to be something
from my past that's it it could be a
video game that I grew up playing that I
loved or a video game I grew up playing
that I hate it could be a TV show that
inspired me as a kid
or a TV show that I just really freaking
hate or a film whatever I could make it
about Nickelodeon in the 90s I could
make it about 80s sitcoms it could be
anything that's the beauty of it I could
talk about anything I wanted to in depth
and it could really just be a fun
discussion about how whatever that topic
is affected me as a youngster or how
I've changed in regards to how I view it
as an adult it's my excuse to have a
whatever video two times a month and
which I can just talk to you guys about
anything it doesn't have to be tied to
anything so starting this Sunday I'm
gonna relaunch the retro rewind segment
and then every Sunday after that will be
one retro rewind then a hilarious 'ti
retro rewind hilarious 'ti you guys get
the point that way I have a little more
variety and it's just more fun I can
bring you guys different content and the
reason I decided to do this is because
I've had this desire to talk about some
older movies or older TV shows that I've
always wanted to share with you guys my
thoughts on but the way I've been doing
things as I kind of tie things into
things and make it like well hey Batman
vs. Superman is coming out so I'll talk
about DC Comics hilarious ities which
I'm going to do but with the retro
rewind segment I can literally talk
about whatever I want and it's so much
fun because it's like no strings you
know you can just like hey on Sunday I
feel like talking about tremors by the
way that's exactly what I'm going to do
this Sunday one of my all-time favorite
horror comedy guilty pleasures is the
movie tremors is it a hilarious 'ti no
absolutely not I love that movie and its
really not bad it's just awesome and I
love it so I couldn't do a hilarious 'ti
of tremors but a retro rewind talk to
you about the first time I saw it when I
was a kid or what it meant to me as a
kid yes I can do that
so this Sunday my first new retro rewind
will be for tremors and then after that
Hilario city of Supergirl so I just
wanted to let you guys know what I was
planning for the future and it's a
really fun idea and I've always kind of
been scared of scheduled content and
you're like saying I'm going to do
something and always do it so what I
will tell you in this video is that
there may be a possibility that in some
way down the line a Sunday may occur
that I will not be able to do this but I
will do my best to do this every other
Sunday retro rewind hilarious 'ti retro
rewind hilarious ''tis Wow save that a
few times fast where I throw Reba
my point is I want to bring you guys
more fun and interesting content and
just have a good time on my channel I
don't want to become one of those
channels that's bogged down by rules and
a lot of uniformity I just want it to be
fun and different and I like variety and
yes the majority of my content will be
revolving around games anime blu-rays
movies but I like the idea of doing
different and fun things with those
subjects because those are subjects I
love and I hope that I can do that for
you guys and I just want to again thank
you so much for always watching my
videos and sticking with me because I'm
always constantly trying to improve them
and a lot of your suggestions have
really helped me do that and I thank you
guys so much for that because without
you guys I'm just a dumbass in Ohio to
be honest even with you guys I'm still
just a dumbass in Ohio thanks so much as
always for watching guys look forward to
Sunday and my discussion on Kevin Bacon
and his glorious performance in tremors
you guys are the best thanks again and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck bye guys